I did it's a nice turnout for a summer
summer conference we don't have these on
a regular basis in the summer it's
always a little nervous whether people
are going to show up but it's a nice
audience and I was telling our speakers
we have like the whole array of students
and trainees here from the
bioinformatics clinical informatics etc
anyway so we've fortunate enough today
to bring in a couple speakers who who
are local to Portland but actually work
in a very national project for an
organization that you've all heard of
Kaiser Permanente and Kaiser in in many
ways has always been a forward-looking
organization early adopter of electronic
health records other technologies and
now embracing data analytics in a major
way
so our speakers brian sakura and chris
guy are here to tell us about what
they're doing and before they do that i
won't take up too much time but I wanted
to introduce them a little so brian has
been with Kaiser since 2005 he started
as an analyst progressed his way through
successive leadership roles initially in
the Northwest region and extending to
other regions of Kaiser he's been a
leader in Kaiser as analytics efforts
and moving the process from a
decentralized to a coordinated one that
will provide value across the entire
organization he has a master's in
Healthcare Administration from Portland
State and a Bachelors of Finance from
University of Pittsburgh he'll be
speaking with Chris sky who's the
executive director of the analytic
information management in the decision
support group at Kaiser and they're
responsible for the development
maintenance and operation of these
analytics systems he's played also
played
a number of leadership roles and is also
now leading this project Chris has a
bachelor's degree in biology in
chemistry from the University of Puget
Sound a master's in health
administration from the University of
Washington and most importantly paws a
graduate certificate in biomedical
informatics from Oregon Health and
Science University so we're very proud
of him
and it shows you all the great things
that our alumni go off and do so anyways
I won't take any more of their time and
I will turn it over them excellent
yeah so it's so great to be back by the
way yeah so first of all thank you for
the time I'd like to introduce Claudine
Martinez law Claudine is with our team
and if your interest a claudinha has
worked with us for years and years and
years so if you want like the lowdown of
what it's really like you can talk to
her if you're interested in finding out
more about opportunities cutting can
also help you with that so if they're in
if they're or like I said if there are
questions like kind of like how we how
we work at guys or what it means cutting
can certainly help with that as well so
I think Brian are gonna do this a little
bit of tag-team well they'll provide
color I'll kind of go through the slides
I think it'd probably be best for this
to be pretty interactive and so if
you're interested if you have a question
about what we're talking about like it
doesn't make sense or you want more
depth to just ask let's not wait till
the end so it's pretty contextual I mean
like large any large organization we
have like it's like insider baseball
like we have our own terms and concepts
and things so they're like that
proverbial thing there are no dumb
questions like with Kaiser it's like a
language of its own almost so there are
no dumb questions please speak up so
that that's not good not in okay um so I
wanted to start with a little bit oh wow
that's offset is there any way to get
that all on
ah
you want to go up I've like okay so Tess
pretend we're in the middle of a
transformation wrought analytics and
yeah I don't have anything down that
corner anyway that's important the KP
logo yeah we watch all his numbers
that's why we put it there so it's being
blocked out yeah I like it
so khachapuri we're in the middle of a
kind of an analytic transformation and
the program is called a - Oh
analytics the second edition so how we
got to the name I thought I would just
start with a little bit the abstract and
then kind of tell you what I think we'll
what I'd like to go over so this is what
we call a large program that means we
have to go to the board because it's
gonna cost some money and we will be
implementing a cloud base a cloud based
analytic foundation that's part of what
we call our systems of intelligence so I
Kaiser Permanente in our IT world we
have systems of record systems of
engagement and systems of intelligence
and in Withey within each one of those
those areas we have strategies
associated with them and this is one big
piece of our systems of intelligence
that the only piece of our systems of
intelligence strategy is this particular
program so cloud based analytic digital
foundation intended initially to support
kind of our health plan financed in an
operational decision making but with an
eye towards kind of the future perhaps
as well in terms of like more clinical
decision making by Kaiser they're all
they're all sorts of interests around
clinical informatics and so you have to
be so the focus of it right now is more
around health plan finance and
operations I talked about Kaiser is an
organization I think it'll become clear
how big of a thing that is so that's
kind of an abstract of what the program
is so in terms of topics I like to just
so
little bit talk about the mission and an
overview and a little bit about our
technology journey this is a large
program and one of the key things about
running a large program is making sure
you have your North Star like where
you're headed and so we have some
guiding principles I would like to go
over to talk a little bit about how we
govern a large program and the decision
makers who were trying to impact and
then we have a framework for what for
our analytics digital foundation that
I'd like to go over and then I have a
couple slides about the architecture I
have to tell you that I am not I'm not
deep technical right so have an IT
counterpart Ganesh who helps be mightily
when it gets into all of the technology
so if you ask me questions and they seem
like I have dumb answers or no answer at
all that's why especially when we get to
the architecture some of it I know that
so we'll do this and we'll see how it
goes without good Ash and then questions
and discussion at the end so it sounds
like a good good plan okay a little bit
about kaiser permanente so you know our
mission is to provide high quality
affordable health care and improve the
health of our members so kaiser is a I
think of Kaiser as being a delivery
system with a health plan not the other
way around so we're we think of
ourselves as a delivery system we fund
ourselves as a health plan and there's a
there's a that's different than a lot of
other organizations in healthcare that's
kind of how we said that the health plan
please submit is not a small piece this
is our revenue this is how we actually
get revenue into the organization so
it's really important to be good at it
but where we really want to be great at
is providing high-quality efficient
efficient healthcare to our members and
that's really a distinction I mean over
the years Kaiser has become kind of
known for its quality I mean we have
regularly get 5 stars for Medicare's
ratings we regularly get consumer
accolades in terms of our how consumers
perceive Kaiser and this is a change
when it used to be in the 70s and 80s
Kaiser
not that and so we've done an amazing
job over the last mm 10 to 15 years
improving quality a lot of that is the
result of our implementation of our
electronic health record what we call
health connect we are now going to going
on the other piece of that mission which
is affordability so this is a huge
effort at Kaiser Permanente we want to
not only be the highest quality but we
also want to be the most affordable we
actually think that those two things
should coincide with each other so the
affordability initiative our CEO Bernard
Tyson this is his number one thing by
far is that we need to make sure that
healthcare is accessible and analytics
plays a role in that in terms of helping
us figuring out what is the most
efficient and effective way of treating
our members so it all fits together we
have this concept of total health one of
the things I love about Kaiser is I kind
of think of this as being the the
merging of Public Health and a delivery
system is that many of our concepts
because we are at risk so we are
financially at risk for our members the
best thing we want to do is people
healthy right I mean we do not have an
interest in people being a financial
interest in being sick not that other
health care systems don't but we have an
opportunity to actually serve at a very
defined population of our members and
it's really the intersection I think of
as public health and delivery systems
and the use of information systems to
supporters is actually absolutely key
just like it is in public health which
is how do we serve our members you know
how do we actually serve the most
efficient cups some facts about Kaiser
1945 or one of those nation's largest
not-for-profit health plans we have 12
point two million members were made up
of three different organizations a
hospital organization health plan
organization and then I'm gonna get this
wrong six independent medical groups and
the reason I bring that up is that in
doing a large program there are all
sorts of in designing technology that is
intended
to meet the needs of different
organizations there are some things you
need to be really really careful about
and you really need to design well in
terms of giving access security and
access to our information I mean we
think of ourselves as Kaiser Permanente
the world thinks of us as Kaiser
Permanente but we're actually in total
like 15 different organizations more
than that actually I think it's at least
24 yet so you think about security model
alone of a major project is like you
have two hundred and thirteen thousand
employees 20 2014 and about 24 different
legal entities so you have to secure all
that data in a way that meets all the
legal restrictions that come with that
so it's a complex challenge at the core
the reason for it out there is that
there are informatics implications of
having an organization certainly that's
at this scale that I'm sure you all can
get but even with this level of
complexity I think for people outside
they don't really realize how
complicated in an organization and ours
and they want Peet's to think about from
the analytic community perspective we
said we're part of this goal is like
while we're going through this program
as well as like we're trying to shift
from a decentralized analyst
organization to a coordinated analyst
organization which this data
infrastructure that were this program
I'm about to talk about is a critical
component to making that happen
right now we have analysts spread
through all those 40 medical centers we
have analysts in different regions and
we have different programs have
different analyst teams and there's a
lot of overlap and redundants overlap
redundancy and gaps we actually don't
know how many analysts we have in our
organization today that's another
project I'm working on right now is
coming up with the analyst Job
Description so we actually know how many
analysts we have across Kaiser
Permanente the estimates are between
2,000 and 5,000 so is-is-is keep just
keep that organizational people
transformation in mind as Chris talks
about some of the aspects of the
analytics to auto program as well as
potentially we're definitely on a
technology journey and this plays is
kind of where we're going from a
technology standpoint we have one of the
largest you guys probably noticed
implementations of an electronic health
record in the world
probably maybe second to like the VA and
British National Health System but we
have a very very large implementation
elect electronic health record around
all of those regions and for this
there's there's 12 million members over
time we've gone into online we have
pretty good engagement with our members
on our bar portal moving into II visits
and online tools again these things are
very associated with our mission of
trying to be kind of affordable as well
as available to our members so for
organization like Kaiser Eve is it yes
we definitely want to do them it's part
of like being a member part of the value
of being a member we've had some
regulatory things that we've had to do
hit by icd-10 Meaningful Use the whole
ACA conundrum which was a major
regulatory reporting challenge that we
actually had to go through so we've
gotten through some of that we have new
platforms for claims or claim
administration is now done inside of
epic it used to be on a whole bunch of
different systems lab one link which is
our finance system pharmacy revenue
cycle so we've gotten into more kind of
vertical kind of applications as well as
reinforcing kind of some of our
infrastructure where we're going and
this is why I brought this slide up is
important for this project because it
kind of hits in oh and this is the one
this is where it actually mattered so
we're coming out of a wall of data is
coming at Kaiser Permanente so between
the Internet of Things genomics I was at
a meeting with Microsoft and they told
me that one person fully sequenced is a
hundred terabytes of genomic information
multiply that by 12 point 2 million and
you got petabytes and petabytes and
petabytes of data devices so there's
this wall of data that is actually
coming at us and there is
increasing need desire and member
expectations' that we use that
information as part of our as part of
our operations and part of our our
analytics and so the two big pieces of
this strategic priorities are the focus
on actually managing data and analytics
as well as going to the cloud in this
particular project ATL actually does
about it and we will be moving our
analytic plot one of our analytic
platforms one that we're developing to
the MS is or Microsoft Azure cloud kind
of over the next three or four years so
this is kind of like I said when I
started that there it's really important
in a really large program to have
Northstars
on something that everybody can we can
all align on in terms of trying to make
decisions around how we do things and
what we do and these are the North Stars
for our program the things that we are
trying to achieve and it's good in that
brand you kind of just drive back so I
was get the I wanted to describe a
little bit about where we are because
these probably don't make any sense
unless you realize how kind of siloed
and fractured our analytic
infrastructure is currently a kaiser
permanente so we have 28 instances of
epic right 28 instances of epic running
we have 1900 registered systems inside
of Kaiser Permanente so this is
something some system that is being
managed and maintained to meet some
needs so 1,900 of them in total the inn
and the analytics based on that there's
regional people doing analytics they're
functional people doing analytics there
it is widely dispersed distributed in
terms of an organized it and we use
Cognos we use SAS we use our we sequel
use business objects we use tableau it's
no event we know our motto is no vendor
left behind but as like when you think
about that from self-service enable
and user experience it's really not the
best thing we could do for the people
inside our organization so and it's if
you think about it so we have an
affordability an issue initiative we
have a wall of data coming out of this
status and we have a highly distributed
fractured siloed I would go as far to
say balkanized which is a really strong
word analytic infrastructure and and
community and so a big part of this
project is the change management
associated with actually going from here
to there right and so that's why this is
so important is that we need the
organization to agree on what we wanted
to look like when we get done and so the
purpose of the guiding principles is try
to provide that kind of vision what we
want it to be like when we're done some
of these this is a little bit like you
know the scouts oath of Honor I mean
like who can disagree with a
standardization reuse right but let me
see so it's like you look at it kind of
go yeah right well not unless you
understand the perspective of what it's
like to be inside the organization so
let me just go through these a little
bit and provide us and maybe even that's
around about some of the challenges that
we have related to the guiding
principles so self-service enablement
and well obviously we want to make sure
that everybody operates at the - what we
call the top of their license what that
means is this cell service isn't just
about providing our decision makers with
ability to to do analytics that's part
of it but it's also making sure that
everyone can actually be part of
self-service that wall of data is not
you know it's coming at us is not going
the only way we're gonna solve that is
if actually people have their tools that
operate at the top of their license one
of the challenges at Kaiser I suspect
it's true at other organizations is that
we have an IT group we have an analytics
group and the IT groups of the analytics
groups sometimes they really don't get
along all that well
and this is part of making sure that our
IT teams and our analytic teams who are
actually using the
data figure out how to work together
part of this is actually enabling the
analysts the data scientists that we
want to actually be using the technology
flexibility I don't think there's the
biggest one so in this project our
executive sponsors are the the CFO of
our organization Cathy Lancaster and she
has a total passion about
standardization from the seat that she
sits in so we in the analytic community
we fail when the source of variation is
methodology and not performance right
organization like Kaiser I mean how many
different ways can you measure a patient
day how many different ways can you
measure pneumonia how many different
ways can you measure you name it I mean
the events that we want to measure we
need to standardize on them we need to
come up as best we can with standards
that are linear sometimes that doesn't
work that go from you know the point of
Terror all the way to the boardroom
sometimes that's very difficult to do
but the organization to be able to make
sure that we're meeting our objectives
needs to have standardization there have
been lots of situations where our
executives have had information coming
from different analytic groups that say
completely different things like the Tin
Man and The Wizard of Oz which where are
you going we lose face we lose we lose
we lose credibility with our executives
when we done standardized on how we
define things as well as just the
experience so a big portion of this
product project is actually a stand
establishing with this large community
what we expect the standards and best
practices to be because we can't get to
that point without actually saying
having people commit to using things
things like tools right which is there's
no economy to having every bi suite in
in the world implement it there's just
no value to it I mean they're good ones
they're bad ones from my perspective
they're mostly do a lot of the same
thing any one of them can work so speed
the insight so this is the amount of
time that it takes between having data
and actually finding inside and make
King action there are a huge with the
amount of data that we have there's just
a processing issue with this one of the
beauties of the cloud is that it's
massively parallel it's very elastic and
can scale quickly to meet new demands
many of our systems inside of Kaiser
Permanente are analytic systems run at
20 to 25 percent utilization in terms of
looking at CPU memory disk any of it
analytic systems of by their nature are
very batchi you know we run things we
run a model that we run at the end of
the day and of the week end of the month
end of the year
unlike systems record which have
relatively more normal kinds of
utilization patterns so one of the speed
to insights is actually going to the
cloud which is we can scale up and scale
down to meet the needs and spend a lot
less money
spinning cycles on on infrastructure
that doesn't get I think a good example
of improvement here is like especially
in the month in like days one through
five for the next month we have some
jobs that process they take two to three
days to finish and if it fails you guys
start two to three days again so it was
like speed in size like this is a very
excited to remove that barrier from our
processes and the hill lhasa become much
more nimble uneven I'm not just new work
but even just routine tasks that have
challenges and hiccups every now and
then like everything does um user
experience so it needs to be compelling
and consistent from a methodology
standpoint being agile in terms of
actually how we develop solutions so we
will be using some of you may be know
about agile and the agile methodology as
a software development lifecycle this
program will use agile it's a little new
to us but the idea of agile
methodologies is that instead of having
the massive plan which by the time you
get done with the plan the plan is an
end in itself not a means to an end with
agile you set kind of high expectations
for how you're going to I'm going to
achieve the endpoint and you just get
down to the work and you try to do it
much more agile II
so we will be using agile as our
methodology I think the biggest one in
the biggest one that probably has the
most value to the organization is
reusability so kaiser permanente we have
a chief data officer that we work very
closely with and they did this
interesting study at Kaiser where they
looked at the total amount of data that
we have and then they looked at the
amount of data that we have in our
systems of record and what they found is
it was 10 to 1 so 10 cop on average
making 10 copies of system of record
data and there are reasons why you're
gonna have why that is always going to
be a number greater than 1 but 10 is
ridiculous at our scale they actually
call yeah actually that's chief data
officer actually call me say Chris I
can't believe this number and I was like
well actually I have 4 copies of myself
a big portion of this project is about
developing a framework that allows us to
lay down the data once in one place
bring it all together across all those
regions and entities and enable people
to reuse it to extend it so a lot of the
framework we're gonna be talking about
is how do we get analytic teams to
instead of making yet another copy of
the data actually just extend what we
have let's put it all together this will
free up if we think it will free up a
tremendous number of resources and
capacity so that we can actually start
working on all of those all of the other
data that we actually haven't really got
had the time to do because we're
managing 10 copies of it
quality enablement the I mentioned we
have a chief data officer at Kaiser
they're responsible for data quality
this is a folks in analytics we have a
huge responsibility and data quality
because sometimes we're the only ones
who see them especially consistency and
issues of consistency so 20-some odd
instances of epic you can imagine how
many encounter types we have how many
visit types we have across all that and
many of them are
mean exactly the same thing so there's a
huge mastering problem have you are are
the 20 versions of epic 20 instances of
epic similar I mean in terms of their
data dictionaries and other kinds of
things or not so I'm not why not
it's someplace between here and there
okay so we had as part of the
implementation of epic we had national
build and many of the applications there
was an intent to try to implement them
nationally and in some areas they're
more consistent and but in other areas
that are very inconsistent I think a lot
of the later early on there was more
consists in inconsistency than there is
today's like Oh some of the more recent
builds are more similar than different
but the earlier ones were more different
than similar you know epic is
encouraging people to go back to their
foundational system for interoperability
and other kinds of reasons yeah
definitely yeah I mean it's interesting
that the places where we find the data
to be the most similar is when there's
an external administrative need for it
to be similar which is disappointing you
know revenue is an amazingly powerful
thing to get actual consistency and data
definition there is one of the things
about bringing the data together is that
it's easier to find where there are
variations so and I've had people inside
of Kaiser say well you can't bring all
this data together it's all different
I'm like it's all different anyway I
mean I mean yes I mean well first of all
yes we can do it I mean the issue is
making sure that people recognize that
there can be variations from instance to
instance but if you actually want to
find those variations you actually have
to bring it together it's the easiest
way to find it so yep we're gonna gotta
go okay yep a decision makers so Tiger
Permanente we have a lot of everybody in
an organization
as a decision maker we all need to
become analysts the idea that we'll have
this analyst class who answers people's
questions is a fallacy everybody needs
to be an analyst at some level we will
still always have professional analysts
but intent is that we through
self-service distribute analytics and
that we grow a culture that is always
looking at the data to figure out what
the evidence says
and what we can discover at Kaiser
Permanente we have this kind of window
pane where we look at our
decision-makers kind of we put them on
on two dimensions so our members
patients and groups so the groups that
we sell our product to kind of point of
care service and sales in our leadership
and this other doesn't show up really
great here the intent of this project is
to serve mostly our leaders as well as
our sales and group management what that
means is that the actual analytics that
are at the point of care and clinical in
analytics needs to be embedded in
workflow it needs to be part of the
implementation we do believe that by
bringing all of our data together we can
actually develop better models using the
power of all of kaiser's data and that
there probably will be able to be used
in the in as models I always think of
models is like give me the coefficients
right so we believe that the models
could be deploy that we could be useful
for point of care that the direct point
of care will continue to come from
within our systems of record
mostly health connect so the intent of
this is is more exhibit kind of
executives functional leaders local
leaders and our sales account management
in groups you would be surprised how
interested especially the kind of sales
and group people are about clinical and
clinical effectiveness and measures that
are more clinical in nature so
in running a large program it's really
important to get your governance
straight these are the people who are
gonna stand behind you and the goin gets
tough and in a project like this there
will be there will be lots of political
and resistance and you know we have two
hundred and twenty thousand people who
may have some interest in this that we
need so this is how we've organized our
our program we have executive sponsors
this is our CIO and our CFO as well as
the leaders for quality and finance from
our Medical Group so super important for
us to weave our Medical Group partners
into all of this so we have Medical
Group partners who are kind of within
the whole in the whole program we have a
steering committee in a community of
practice or community of practice I told
you about how important the standards
are our community of practice is where
we go to to a line on standards
oftentimes with standards it's you
somebody have to give something up right
negotiation happens when everybody is
willing to give something up and so we
have to bring together our community of
practice the people and try to get get
them to agree on the value of having
standards because somebody's going to
give something up probably the actual
delivery so the actual delivery of the
value so you put together a business
case for a large program you have to
identify where you're gonna bring value
and it's monetized we have a net present
value it's finance that we had to take
to our board to actually get it approved
and this is the this is the piece that
actually delivers on the program
actually does the work so it's broken
typically broken up into tracks in this
case the tracks are kind of going this
way we'll talk about the framework and
the foundational data and services that
are going to support all of these
different use cases for it it's all
wrapped together by a program management
office so actually the people who
actually help us make sure that we're
doing the right things and in the rights
all right that's kind of all the high
level program what the what the program
is about how we're organizing a piece of
it but in from a technology standpoint
you need to have a framework to think
about how you're gonna do this and this
is the framework that we have we're
actually up meeting with Microsoft we
actually shared as a partner we shared
with them we asked like a big
organization super complicated we want
to move all the impolitic data like how
do you do it what have you guys learned
and they brought up a framework that
looked almost exactly like this and I
went well at least we're not gonna mess
up this program because we didn't get
the framework right we might mess it up
for whole another reason but it's not
because the actual way to think about
the problem is not correct right so the
framework is based
I hate hierarchies I don't know about
you guys but I saw I was a biology major
right like cells I actually like cells
better because it's better way of
thinking of it but I tell you what in
organizations people like hierarchy I
don't know these things don't whenever I
look at this I always go that they all
work together right they intend to work
together so the platform that and the
framework that we have is that we have
this analytics digital foundation that
is made up of foundational services and
foundational data this is the shared
part of the environment right so we
intend to have a variety of different
tenants that are represented by these
cute buildings on the top reusing data
for meeting different decision-making
needs so that is in a in a nutshell what
the model is which is we have a shared
how they should have different tenants
who deliver value to decision-makers and
they build off of a common of a common
foundation in this model the tenant is
where the value is there's no reason to
have all this gobbledygook if the if we
do not have well-defined decision-making
communities and problems to solve we
envision that
as part of this program we could have
hundreds of different tenants who are
reusing data for different
decision-making communities so they
could be functional revenue management
or risk adjustment or claims
administration they could be regional
that could be project oriented we have a
lot as a large organization and
healthcare is highly highly regulated
and we oftentimes have regulations that
we have to respond to and oftentimes
very quickly and they always require
some kind of reporting environment so we
envision tenants being able to be
developed quite quickly the foundation
services is made up of kind of
foundational data management services
these are things like data quality and
metadata when the stuff that you talked
about actually having data catalogs that
actually allow us to discover what data
we have and what it means what the
lineage of it is you know kind of
platform and infrastructure services of
these are the things like we need an
ingestion framework we need a way that
we can ingest from a multitude of
different systems real-time and batch
data from our systems of record and
external sources so it's an example of a
platform service and then the analytic
services the things that everybody gets
real excited about you know the business
intelligence layers the artificial
intelligence kind of advanced analytics
some of this stuff has evolved so much
sometimes people know it I know that I
actually know what some of these things
are it's just become a maze of analytic
services some of it is very very cool
they're just immense number of them from
a data standpoint there will be three
kind of zones within the foundation we
will ingest raw data um so I have a
colleague because this great saying that
I love
he says data is like fruit the more you
touch it the worse it gets and if this
is a actually I think about this like
I'm lossy you guys know about like MPEG
and JPEG lossy right all you can do if
you capture information about an event
all you can do with the data is make it
worse right it's just like you know on
Facebook I post pictures they screw up
you know it's so la si or MPEG it's so
lossy same thing here
do no harm right just bring so we have
20 some-odd instances of epic right i
have 1900 systems we want much of the
data from those all of those to be on on
just bring it in put it in some place
catalog it but don't touch it
right don't start manipulating it when
you do that we will do that but don't do
that initially do it do it once you get
and this is a big change for Kaiser it's
a big change for how many analytics
systems have been designed and it's part
of the concept of a data Lake which is
kind of a deep way of thinking of it
once we have all this right raw data
there will be a zone where we refine it
this is the process of curating data so
it's useful for decision making at a
good example of refinement of data is we
have these all these different instances
of epic we will put all of the data
together or put a region code on it our
our data is organized by region in the
system of record and conform it so we
will find a common model and we'll put
it in a common law that brings value by
just ease of use easier to find the data
if it's all actually brought together at
the top of this we have this concept of
shared enrichments and rules it's
actually a really good art analytic
article at Harvard Business Review from
like a year or so ago that talked about
multiple a single source of truth
multiple versions of truth the concept
is that you can have all of this data
but there are oftentimes different
reasons why you want to process it in
different ways you could have different
regulatory definitions you could have a
whole bunch of different reasons that
you want to actually process it
differently and so by having all of your
data in one place and having this
enrichment layer where the rules are
clearly identified and distinctly put
under framework you can actually
understand the lineage and provenance of
analytics just like you understand the
lineage and Providence of of systems of
record data alright that's the frame
this is my favorite slide coming up is
it I just love looking at all the boxes
so so this is great so this is like okay
this is like really embarrassing right
so we had to put we had we had somebody
said well like what's in that I don't
get it
so like about half of my job is actually
trying to translate informatics to
executives right and they're
well-intentioned but I'll tell you why
they're demanding they're super
demanding you know whom you tell me give
me examples I don't get it
so I sat down one night and actually
just I started typing at 6.5 that's how
we ended up this is in no way expended
to be all of it but this is some
examples of the kinds of information
that we all have in these different
levels and what we will what we will
actually do with it what I like about
the slide is you look at the the
categories of data and how it's
organized from our systems out to the
like the the healthcare domains and
actually after the dimensional models
are the enrichments that we can apply to
it is like you think about like
organizing this once and then being able
to use it by the by the analytic
community up in that tenant level like
what a transformation this will be from
where we are today where every and I
every analytic project we have where 90%
of the effort is obtaining access to the
data structuring the data getting it
ready for use is like this will do that
for us and it's going to completely
change like where we are today and where
will be from three years from now from
like what what an analyst does inside
our organization will be completely
different because of this structure
that's like so I love thinking about all
the different pieces you can piece
together and like what we're gonna be
able to do with it that's I'm glad you
did that
no it's fantastic I love it yeah yeah
the one of the one of the common
challenges of Geysers that we don't is a
rationalization problem which is
everybody like segmentation member
segmentations we have a lot of people
who want to look at our business by
different segments whether it's by the
product that they purchase the line of
business
region they came from and what we find
is that there are a whole bunch of
people who do this independently and
part of this model is that concept of
shared enrichment says rules is we need
to find one person to do it we all need
to agree to it and live with it right
because right now part of the reason we
end up with different answers for
executives is because it's not intent or
it's a it's not intents that we're not
organized right so part of the standards
and best practices is actually coming to
agreement on who's responsible for what
in our analytic environment so anyway
lab that's eye candy like super big
candy
we actually have an even bigger one let
me get it free it's like wall-sized
because we're actually starting to get
into more levels of detail let me talk a
little bit about where we think the kind
of current state and future stayed and
why we're doing it and Brian you brought
up actually a really good point that is
one there was some great works that he's
done looking at what just what data
scientists actually spend their time
doing and what they discovered is that
data scientists spend about 70% of their
time doing what we call data wrangling
and about 25% of the time actually
trying to find insight so what is data
wrangling data wrangling is getting
access to the data right I mean before
you can do anything you actually have to
have your TNS names or however you're
going to connect yeah got to get that
baby set up so you can get access to the
data there are situations at Kaiser
Permanente where it will take two to
three months to get access to data right
that's got to go away it's gotta go away
so data wrangling is data quality it's
bringing it together it's putting it on
one platform it's trying to figure out
how to provision the resources to do it
so 2575 we want to flip that we want
data science they're really expensive
and the work they do is cool I can't
believe that they're not frustrated
sitting there trying to figure out how
to wrangle all this data together yeah
they are totally that's right we're
gonna decide we're gonna say we want you
to spend 75 percent of your time
actually doing what you love to do and
where we get the most value which is
actually analyzing the data 25 percent
doing that this is kind of before and
after I talked about
top-1 which is the amount of utilization
we want to move to have way higher
utilization of our resources we want to
have people amo spending their time you
know not doing data prep as much we will
move from the kind of ETL where we come
up with these elaborate models data
models and then we torture our data to
fit in some data model that's not how
data lakes work
it's an ELT model where you essentially
just take the data as it is bring it
into a data Lake and part of that shirt
enrichment layer is actually developing
schemas to represent the data in
different ways and we see a huge
opportunity to be using and leveraging
the community beyond Kaiser perhaps to
actually find insight there are common
data models that run around in the in
the that people have come up with like
Oh mop and coronet others like that
where if we can form our data to look
like how others look like it we can
actually leverage other people's code
and insights to see if it applies to
Kaiser so um the trans transformation
from a traditional data warehouse to a
kind of next-generation data warehouse
the data Lake we think it will provide
huge opportunities to use the kind of a
larger communities knowledge we talked
about silos to a managed data platform
one of the other big challenges is a
tool challenge at Kaiser I think this is
probably true in many organizations
we're using a lot of proprietary
software we hoped as part of this to
move beyond that to be using as much
open-source as we can most a lot of
times is because the science data
scientists the people that we're trying
to work with this is actually what
they're being trained in this is a huge
change management issue because we have
people who have demesne knowledge of our
data who understand legacy tool so you
have to be very careful about that the
actual knowledge those people have about
the data is super important and have it
transition I used to be a contender I
used to actually be able to write code I
don't do it anymore but learning a new
language is not easy
I mean and and so we need to be very
careful about the transformation but the
idea is that we're trying to move to
where to where the market of talent is
going which is to open source yeah
that's a very big change for us I think
I know I've seen that we've been up
spend a lot of time up here over the
years and I think is like some of you
guys and I was like we've been very
heavy SAS Cognos informatica over those
years and through the interactions like
I mean graduates from this program
coming and to this thing we don't know
SAS we use our we want and we get more
more cooling we don't use our and I was
like okay so we're we're going on that
public like our CFO saying we're gonna
go we're gonna leverage open source
tools because it's a major major shift
for our organization I think it's the
right shift to do but it's like the
Chris was raised like the change
management we have worry we have in
front of us as it's more its culture
change I mean it this is a significant
piece of culture change for our
organization to make this transformation
from an infrastructure standpoint moving
to the cloud going horizontal in terms
of vertical being able to spin up
resources when you need them and just
the probability to provision so this is
a kind of a crazy thing so I Kaiser or
if you need to if we need to get new
capacity inside of our existing data
centers it's probably nine months to a
year if you can get her to put it in
there at all so if you have a new need
just the amount of time it takes you to
actually get the computing power you
need to do your work it's like a year
that's got to go you know we spend
immense amounts of time going from one
version of Oracle to the next version of
Oracle I'm done with that I do not care
that's absolutely zero value and nobody
cares at the end Microsoft does it in
the middle of the night they make an
update awesome you know I do not have to
worry about another Oracle upgrade
honestly we spend millions of dollars
moving from one version of it to another
version of it there's no value to
remember it none of doing that so having
it be this is what's called
platform-as-a-service so Microsoft
provides the infrastructure they provide
the data centers out there in the gorge
any of them
they provide the tools we build on top
of it we get out of the business of
actually having to manage that
infrastructure I'm glad to get out of it
there is an implication but there are
people inside of your IT organization
where that's their job you know and this
becomes very terms of the change
management that becomes very very
challenging discussions talk about the
economies and at the end of the day it's
an economy or never it's gonna happen
the other issues if just one okay next
slide
oh my ok where I need Ganesh so this is
how the foundation is intended work
actually that's what I kind of know it's
the next one whatever tell me what it is
so we capture data or systems of record
we will have both batch and someplace on
in a real-time way of ingesting it in we
will create this data lake this is that
single source of truth
this is Hadoop you its HDFS it's the
Microsoft version of Hadoop so it's a
massively parallel file system is where
the data will land in the process of
moving that in we catalog it we profile
it and we tag it some important things
that happen in those stages so Brian
talked about the importance of securing
this information you have to tag it to
be able to secure it and so the tagging
of data elements so that you know what
to secure is a really important thing to
do
from there we organize it a kind of for
tenant consumption create these
refinements data is more commonly
becoming like a service so data as a
service is where we're going which is we
expect different groups to expose their
data to other people on the platform and
to manage it so I'll give you an example
at Kaiser Permanente we do a lot of risk
adjustment our risk adjustment is the
process by which we give every member at
a point in time a score that measures
their risk relative to others
we're required for regulatory reporting
we use it for helping to stratify our
members and patients for making sure we
get them in the right categories and a
whole bunch of other stuff that is a
service right what the community wants
is one person to do risk adjustment and
expose it to the community this is an
enrichment so a definition of enrichment
is we're creating new data case of in
the case of risk adjustment we're
getting that score so there are a whole
bunch of models like that I mean luckily
some of these models run natively in
different languages and in different
scenarios and different tools and
software the hope here is that we can
expose them in a common way
so that they can be reused so we don't
have multiple people doing risk
adjustment for example all of this goes
into this kind of tenant area where we
build our analytic assets so we draw
from that shared enriched data and we
develop the reporting at the end of this
is this concept of what we call data
access objects and user access objects
this is how we actually are planning to
actually secure the data so role-based
security the whole concept of role-based
security works really well in systems of
record where you have a defined workflow
and you can put people in roles it does
not work as well for analytics
I mean analysts tend to want data and
the more data they can get the better
right especially the data scientists and
so there's a we're proposing a model I
think is actually kind of novel which is
exciting and scary at the same time I
think which is to actually say that for
analytic world your access to data what
data you have access to find your a role
as opposed to the function that you
perform within it so we will be
organizing are they our data based on
use so that we can then assign people
access to areas of use based on it so
and then at the end of it it goes who it
all goes to the decision-makers today
I'm gonna try this one
Ganesh please okay I did we got down
questions I went so fast or we went so
fast yeah thanks for this inspiring talk
um sounds like you have some very
innovative things that are happening
there I was just curious um is there a
particular approach that you have to
textual data in from our from what
standpoint like like no text for example
the like the classic assumption is that
like like the the data that's contained
in free text is not really usable I was
just wondering if there's like a
strategy there you have either like
using like epics like smart elements or
like NLP in some flavor or Cho to
leverage um so we do some of that right
now I mean because this is initially
focused mostly on finance operational
oral health plan kind of data most of
the data that's been codified is kind of
the target but we have used quite
successfully natural language processing
to help actually validate some of the
coding that we do we actually have in
Southern California or Southern
California has been a kind of a region
has been kind of a pioneer and actually
reading clinical notes and helping it to
either validate the diagnosis or the
clinical term um it's it's kind of
complicated to do you have you know
sensitivity specificity errors you know
statistical errors that you need to
really be careful about especially if
you're using it for any kind of
decision-making around character but
it's really good at actually identifying
things to look at so in terms of
improving the quality of your classified
data it's really good for that you have
to be careful about using it at the
point of care because of those the
statistical
I'm almost positive that Microsoft if
you go so if you go to the azure webpage
so when we decided to use the zarur I'm
enough of a goober that I decided to do
this which is we said oh we're gonna use
Asura's iCloud I know what that's like I
went out provisioned myself an account
I've got a sequel server and
implementation of our and power bi I
loaded a bunch of data onto it created a
little application is just one to see
how easy it was to do it's remarkably
easy which is cool what's really
interesting is when you go to Microsoft
site and AWS or Google it's the same
thing is how many services that they can
provision on the cloud it's insane in
terms of the software so there is
natural language or every they're all
probably four or five services that will
help you with help you with natural
language processing and I'm pretty sure
my Kurt has Microsoft has one that's
inherent to it
so I was curious about your timeline and
I don't need mentioned about three years
but could you give us a sense of of the
chunks of the project and how long it
takes to do each part of that chunk sure
so as part of so kaiser permanente we've
implemented like tons and tons and tons
of systems or 1900 of them so and big
ones as well and we have a we have a
little bit of a discipline around
programs and one of the things that we
have learned is that programs can't take
too long if it takes too long it doesn't
get done and so we proposed this program
we actually proposed it much longer and
our CFO and CIO came in said nah we're
doing this in three or four years you
gotta get it done in three or four years
part of is the organization just kind of
loses interest which is really weird to
think but that's I'm not being honest
it's like so the doing this in three or
four years is a stretch especially given
the component the when I shared the
foundation if you were doing this
rationally you'd build from the bottom
up right you develop your foundational
services you've been foundational data
and but because the organization's and
and this is not just Kaiser Kaiser is
awesome this is any organization people
will lose interest you have to deliver
value along the way otherwise people
will be like your exact it's like what
those guys do it anyway you know so we
will be delivering some value along the
way the first couple years of it is
really laying down those foundational
services and the foundational data that
many people will use but we are doing
some things on an interim basis to keep
the our executives happy along the way
so the first portion of the program is
really about mostly about developing
that foundation and then the last part
of the program is having our tenants or
the people who deliver value actually
use it so when the business case was
approved everybody celebrated
I went for a long walk and thought oh my
god now we actually have to do it and
when I thought about the problem of
actually having to do this I thought
well we have to go parallel we actually
can't do this serial there's too much
work to be done to be done in parallel
and so the approach that we're going to
actually take and we will see if this
works is to actually run this like any
other software company would run this
right which is essentially the
foundational services and foundational
data need to be opened up and documented
and we need to let our analytic
community and developers develop on it
so we're actually developing what we're
gonna call a tenant development toolkit
which tells them about the standards and
the services that are there available
we're going to develop a reference
implementation another part of toolkits
that's quite useful if you want to
develop which is how do you actually do
it and we are hoping to have most of our
tenants which are going to be doing the
development of the shared enrichments
and the reporting and all of the models
go parallel so I think that that's the
right way to do it said of going if it
goes serial it'll never get I don't
think you can get done for three or four
years so that's our hope so I had a
question about that the middle layer of
the foundation data which i think is
fantastic this idea of the refined level
of data and I know for the work that I
do that I mean you're talking about
going flipping that model of 20 versus
75 or 25 or 75 that's potentially huge
so my question is and I also really like
that you're keeping
it's information which is really
valuable how are you going to ensure the
validity of the processes that take the
data from that raw stage to this
harmonized stage and doing that mapping
and also are you going to make the raw
data available this is that is actually
that is actually the question that all
that is you back the second all the
music the second one first people have
asked that here's the challenge the
challenge with Hadoop and file systems
is they're really hard to secure I mean
this isn't that you can't do it here's
the challenge of IT challenging with
ideas they can do anything you want them
to do the issue is the level of effort
what does it take to do it not one day
so somebody in this room will probably
say yeah you can secure it and I will
challenge you with whether at this scale
you can do it right now our arm model or
our assumption is that we will not allow
access to raw data mostly because it's
hard to secure and we that's super
important with all those organizations
and entities but we will move everything
from raw to refined so your second
question how do you ensure the validity
of those models part of it is is to so
we have a team Claudine is knows this
very well that will be responsible for
making sure that as data moves the lossy
thing right you don't want to lose
fidelity and the data as it moves from
stage to stage so we will you be using
tools to actually validate data quality
as it moves from these different layers
there's actually this is really
interesting to me because every Sykes so
fascinated with AI and so am I kind of
I'm all scared by it as well fascinating
scared at the same time but there is
actually data quality ai and I think
that's actually a phenomenal use of data
of AI is to actually look at data
quality it seems to me you should be
able to go multi-dimensional and find
when you start to see cell sizes that
are unlike other cell sizes based on
different dimensions of data it's
probably a data quality problem so one
of the tools were actually looking at is
actually a pride to date data qualities
yeah yeah yeah yeah actually data quit
yeah yeah we're over I'm sorry sorry but
quick quick
you mentioned that there was a lot of
different or like 3,000 analyst in your
system well yes they are becoming more
attendants in this case were you having
planned to have them talk to each other
so example if they are doing similar
work on something they can share their
work yep yep yeah part of this is part
part of this platform is will include a
series of what we're calling the
knowledge management tools and I
actually think we'll end up with an
analytic librarian role at some point um
we're gonna have a standard one standard
we're using the Alaskan product suite so
JIRA for requests and demand management
bitbucket for code repository and
confluence for project artifacts
analytic documentation QA forms and like
best practice libraries them through
that I think through the bitbucket
confluence and maybe even I'd love to
see like HipChat be used as well as like
integrated and with that I think that
that the that sort of tools to enable
the analyst to communicate with one
another and connect them as a community
coupled with this with the single data
environment I think will achieve that
vision great thanks I know we could
probably go on and since Brian and Chris
are local they're around they actually
participate in our hybrid course that
Shannon also leads and Ted and Ted and
and and and also Virginia is learning
more and more about their needs so can
give you advice if you're thinking that
you might want to pursue this and they
actually have hired other graduates of
ours so I just want to thank them and
thank you for a great talk yeah thank
you thank you
and we are trying to hire so if you want
to be part of this program she's the
woman to talk to before she leaves here